many of the Democrats who hope to
challenge the president in next year's
election are joining the course of
criticism over last night's chant
correspondent Peter Doocy shows us that
tonight candidates claim to be concerned
that after an L hon Omar inspired send
her back chant the 2020 election is no
longer just about right or left
it's about life or death if I were her I
would you know immediately call the FBI
and say what do I need for protection
Connolly Harris and Elizabeth Warren
both described the president's
re-election rally as racist and
xenophobic and Jill Biden tried to add
historical context when the crowd
started yelling send them back send them
back extend them back when has that ever
happen over the last time you remember
anything about George Wallace but
strategists argue squaring off against
some of the most politically progressive
members of the House can carry some
rewards he's managed to make them the
face of the Democrat Party that's genius
that's great it's wonderful politics
wish there was a better way he could
have done it still nearly two dozen
Democrats are focused on President Trump
as president Trump narrows his focus to
5-1 Joe Biden he's not prepared he's not
mentally prepared that's his problem
- Bernie Sanders he's actually not even
a Democrat isn't an independent that
he's running but he missed this time 3
Kamala Harris they have a new one who
knocked the hell out of Biden during a
debate for Elizabeth Warren
I was driving her crazy so she went out
and hired a guy to check the blood and
five people judge if that's the hot
young star I guess I just don't know
stardom anymore that is not a star but
the big stars on the left this week are
the freshman Democrats and the so-called
squad who could be doing President Trump
a favor every time they speak or tweet
he should thank them and the reality is
they're getting further and further out
of the mainstream in 2016 candidate
Trump found himself in the middle of
fights with lawmakers entertainers even
the Pope and he's still won the election
so now rivals and supporters might have
to consider this could be part of a
strategy maybe it
wasn't at the beginning but it is now
bright I think that's clear Peter thank
you